[Music]
crazy stuff happened over the weekend
Secret Service involved in a sex scandal
you following this story yeah 11 Secret
Service agents are in trouble for
reportedly having sex with a prostitute
while on a trip to Colombia yeah in
their defense the Secret Service agents
are saying it's part of their oath to
put themselves in Ho's way that's what I
like well you're gonna give him back
[Applause]
that's right 11 Secret Service agents
reportedly had sex with prostitutes
people got suspicious when they noticed
Secret Service agents wearing nothing
but their sunglasses and earpieces
completely nude walking around no people
are wondering how the Secret Service
agents were discovered in the first
place yeah apparently one prostitute
figured out they were Secret Service
when her client pulled out a condom and
yelled secure the perimeter
MIT Romney seems like he's what are you
looking at I'm just thinking about how
I'm gonna explain that to my kid cuz he
watches the show there's your first
mistake right there
my my kids think I'm a realtor
never in a million years am I gonna tell
them what I really do
he's a realtor yeah
of course it seems official and MIT
Romney is the GOP candidate that's you
know not official yet but it seems
official Mitt Romney has already begun
the process of choosing a running mate
did you know that
yeah Romney wants someone with a
different ethnicity who appeals to women
so his first choice is President Obama
today in my hometown of Boston the 116th
Boston Marathon was won by a woman from
Kenya and a man from Kenya now it was a
very exciting race both winners narrowly
edged out someone from Kenya
[Music]
[Laughter]
people are criticizing Mel Gibson
because Mel Gibson's trying to make a
movie about the Jewish hero of Hanukkah
yeah apparently people really have a
problem with Gibson's title for the film
the Jew who stole Christmas
[Applause]
it's on the sled a little dog with the
antlers a British Historical Society
declared that Britain's greatest foe of
all time was George Washington our
George Washington yeah coming in second
place was Adolf Hitler and third place
third place went to Madonna's accent
[Applause]
this is good news
Brad Pitt and Angelina Jolie announced
that they're engaged
nice apparently Brad Pitt got down on
one knee
accidentally knelt on a kid
they're everywhere you see over the
weekend a 3d hologram of the late Tupac
Shakur performed at Coachella with Snoop
Dogg crazy yeah
yes nuke Dogg praise the advanced
technology that made Tupac appear by
saying this is some crazy weed
speaking of weed and I don't get to say
that often on this show you know what
the hottest new trend in California is
right now the keulen Airy trend red wine
laced with marijuana yeah yeah I don't I
don't have a joke for this I was just
asked to announce this by the California
Board of tourism
you